[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Please join me
in welcoming Patrisse Khan
Cullors.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Hi, Google Seattle.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
I like lively audiences,
so please feel free to mhm,
and ashay, and amen.
This is the introduction to
the book "We Are Stardust."
Days after the
election of 2016, Asha
sent me a link to talk about
afrophysicist Neil deGrasse
Tyson.
We have to have hope, she says
to me across 3,000 miles--
she in Brooklyn,
me in Los Angeles.
We listen together as
deGrasse Tyson explains
that the very atoms and
molecules in our bodies
are traceable to the crucibles
in the centers of stars
that, once upon a time,
exploded into gas clouds.
And those gas clouds
formed other stars.
And those stars possess
the divine right mix
of properties needed to
create not only planets,
including our own--
but also people,
including us-- me and her.
He is saying that not only
are we in the universe,
but that the universe is in us.
He is saying that
we, human beings,
are literally made
out of stardust.
And I know when I hear
deGrasse Tyson say this
that he is telling the truth.
Because I have seen it
since I was a child--
the magic, the stardust
we are, and the lives
of people I come from.
I watched it in the
labor of my mother,
a Jehovah's Witness, and a woman
who worked two and sometimes
three jobs at a time.
Keeping other people's children,
working in the reception desk
at Jim's, telemarketing--
doing anything and everything
for 16 hours a day, the whole
of my childhood in the Van Nuys
barrio where we lived.
My mother, cocoa
brown and smooth,
disowned by her family
for the children
she had as a very young
and unmarried woman.
My mother never gave up, despite
never making a living wage.
I saw it in the thin brown
face of my father, a boy out
of Cajun Country.
A wounded healer whose
addictions were born
of a world that did not
love him and told him
so not once, but constantly.
My father, who
always came back, who
never stopped trying to be a
better version of himself--
there were no mirrors for.
And I knew it, because
I am the 13th generation
progeny of a people who survived
the hulls of slave ships--
survived the chains,
the whips, the months
laying in their
own shit and piss.
The human being's
legislator that
is not human beings who watch
their names, their languages,
their goddesses and gods,
the Ark of their dances
and beats of their songs,
the majesty of their dreams,
their families snatched
up and stolen--
disassembled and discarded--
and despite this,
built language and honored God
and created movement and upheld
love.
What could they be but
stardust, these people who
refused to die?
Who refused to accept the
idea that their lives did not
matter, that their children's
lives did not matter.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Well, first, let me
just start by thanking you.
For me in particular,
I will start
with a personal
note of that that's
very meaningful-- as a
career woman of color,
as an immigrant, as
I mentioned to you.
This, for me, is a big honor.
So I appreciate that, thank you.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: I actually want to
talk a little bit about--
you start this story by history,
talking about your family,
in particular-- and your
mom, and your brother,
and your father.
And you focus a lot on this idea
of collective responsibility
versus personal responsibility.
So I'd actually ask you to talk
a little bit more about that.
Why do you believe
that this focus
that we have on
personal responsibility
can be so detrimental,
particularly
to black individuals?
And what is there
to gain from moving
to this idea of call activity?
PATRISSE CULLORS:
It's a great question,
because I was
literally just talking
to a reporter about this
when I got off the plane.
Which is-- for many of us, who
grew up in poor neighborhoods,
who grew up in poverty--
the experience we had
was it was our fault.
We were blamed for our families
being unable to feed us.
We are blamed for our
families addictions.
We were blamed for the state
coming after our family.
We were blamed for
so many things that
had everything to do with
a system that was literally
created to harm and
decimate communities.
And so the question
becomes, who is accountable?
Is it the people who
are most at the margins?
The people who have experienced
some of the most suffering?
Or is it the system--
is it local government,
is it state government,
is it federal government?
And as we live under this
current administration,
how do we hold it accountable?
How do we hold local government
accountable to actually produce
laws that will
support human beings,
produce policies that
will support human beings,
And how do we challenge the
idea that a young mother, who
had a child at 16, deserves
to be kicked out of her home?
Deserves to not receive
the type of support
and aid just because she
had children out of wedlock,
or just because she had
a child at a young age.
I mean, these are the
kinds of questions
that we need to ask ourselves.
And I think what happens,
because we live in a culture--
and America, in
particular-- that
really values personal
respond to responsibility,
really values the idea
of pulling yourself up
by your bootstraps.
Well, that only actually
works for certain people.
And the pulling up
by your bootstraps
is designed for certain people,
and not designed for others.
And when we can have an honest
conversation about the design,
then we can have an honest
conversation about what
it should look like--
how it should look differently.
And so not only am I
challenging the idea
of personal
responsibility, which
I think is different than
asking people to be accountable.
I want to, like,
differentiate those terms.
Someone being responsible
for their own poverty--
no.
But someone being
accountable, being
accountable to their
family, right-- my mother
was accountable to us, because
she worked 16 hours a day.
But she wasn't responsible
for her poverty.
I think we have to be able
to differentiate that.
And the last thing
I'll say on this
is it will take all of us--
it has to be all of us--
to change the system,
to change this place.
To collectively come
together and make a decision.
As many of us say in
Black Lives Matter-- when
black people get
free, everybody else
gets a little bit more free.
SPEAKER: On the Black
Lives Matter movement,
in particular-- the
shooting of Trayvon Martin
and the acquittal of his shooter
is clearly an important moment
in that movement.
Can you speak a
little bit as to why
that moment resonated with
you so powerfully when it did?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Yes.
And what you're
going to notice is
I'm always going to kind
of take a few steps back.
Because a moment is
a moment, but there
are things that lead
up to the moment
that actually makes
that moment the moment.
So for me, it was--
I come from a generation--
I was born in '83--
and so I come from a generation
that witnessed Reagan,
witnessed the Bush's,
witnessed the Clinton's.
And in those presidencies,
what we got to see
was a ratcheting up
of the war on drugs,
a ratcheting up of
mass incarceration,
and ratcheting up
mass criminalization
of very particular
communities-- black communities,
in particular.
And as I grow up--
and as many of us grow up in
this particular era and age
group--
we are sort of the
sacrificed ones.
We're the children
who are being impacted
by deindustrialization.
We're the children
who are being impacted
by the militarized policing.
And so once we get
to Trayvon Martin,
so many things have happened--
'92, Rodney King.
Oscar Grant has happened.
And then Trayvon, although
not killed by law enforcement,
he's killed by a vigilante who
was empowered by a state that
empowers law enforcement.
And so I didn't think
that George Zimmerman
was going to get off.
I was like, he killed
Trayvon Martin.
We all knew that, jury knew it.
I didn't think he was
going to get murder,
but I definitely didn't think
he was going to get to go home.
And when he did on
July 13th of 2013,
I was very clear that
that wasn't going
to be the period to the story--
that we had to do more.
That I had to do
more, personally.
And as I heard Sybrina Fulton--
Trayvon Martin's mother--
specifically speak out through
tears, through grief, and call
on the people of this country
to show up for her child,
to show up for her--
I just felt like it was
incredibly important.
And so I was on social
media, like many of us are,
angry and upset and
trying to figure out
how to understand
what was happening.
And I came across a good
friend's Facebook post--
Alicia Garza-- and she
wrote Black Lives Matter,
and then I put a hashtag on it.
And Alicia was like,
what's a hashtag?
And I was like, it's this
thing that can go viral.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm also a
trained organizer,
so I wasn't just interested
in an online campaign.
I was interested in how
we translated Black Lives
Matter to the ground
and how it really
could be a grassroots movement
that can bubble up, change
the world, change the country.
And on July 15th, when
we solidified Black Lives
Matter as a political project,
I wrote on social media again.
I said, hey, Alicia
and I have started
this project called
Black Lives Matter,
and we hope that it will impact
more than we can ever imagine.
SPEAKER: One of the things you
talk about a lot in your book
is taking that hashtag--
you say that, I think,
hashtag to movement.
So essentially, creating power
under this umbrella of Black
Lives Matter.
What has that journey been like?
What are some of the lessons
you've learned-- challenges,
victories?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Well,
we have to remember
that Black Lives Matter
really started organically.
It started online,
this organic moment.
It was very quickly galvanized
into a political project.
Really, that first
year was nurturing it.
Having people talk
about Black Lives Matter
in their organizations--
at their offices--
having a lot of, like,
conference calls.
How do we use this, taking
it out to the streets
during protests.
But I would say that the
height of BLM, or where
it becomes worldwide, is after
the non-indictment of Darren
Wilson.
And after Mike Brown's
killer is not indicted,
that is the first time it
goes viral on social media.
And I remember being
like, we have to do more.
We have to figure out
what's the next step, what's
the next angle.
And 600 of us went and did
a Black Lives Matter freedom
ride, and we drove
into St. Louis.
And before we drove
in we called folks--
you know, folks let us
know we could come in.
We're not just showing up
to people's neighborhoods.
And on that three day journey--
because it was only three days--
there's two commitments we made.
The first commitment was to show
up for the people of St. Louis,
to let them know
that we're not going
to allow for Ferguson PD--
and every other municipality
law enforcement municipality--
to treat this community
this way without us
watching, witnessing, and
going back and telling
our communities.
But the second
thing that we said
that we wanted to
make sure we did
is go back home and organize.
And build what we
would then build,
which is the Black Lives
Matter Global Network.
Which is an organization of
40 chapters around the globe--
here in the US, in Canada,
and the United Kingdom.
SPEAKER: One of the things that
you discuss on the Black Lives
Matter, in particular,
is this idea
of creating a hashtag
that people would embrace.
And the word black ends up being
sort of a big point of salience
when it comes to it.
And I think more recently
in the tech community,
we've had one diversity leader
say that if you have 12--
I think it's white,
blue-eyed men in a room--
it's a diverse room, because
people have different ideas.
So I want to speak a little
bit about intersectionality,
which is such a big
part of your book.
But also, how do we have
a genuine conversation
about intersectionality without
it becoming an all lives matter
conversation?
Like, how do we actually bring
that in a way that is genuine?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Right.
How do you have a
conversation and practice
about intersectionality,
without whitewashing it?
SPEAKER: Yes
PATRISSE CULLORS: Yes,
because that can happen.
And what is important is
we understand where words
come from, and that words--
what's been really interesting
about this administration is
they basically made words--
what's the word?
SPEAKER: Meaningless.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Meaningless.
You could say, I
hate all N-words.
And then the next breath you
could say, I'm not a racist.
That doesn't even
make sense, right?
But it becomes an argument.
Not just in media,
but it also becomes
an argument in people's
relationships and friendships.
And-- oh, that guy said I
could say this and still not
be a racist,
And I think the word
intersectionality really
comes from a woman
named Kimberle Crenshaw.
And she created
it because she was
trying to challenge
the conversation,
specifically in the
black community--
that the only people
who have the right
to talk about black folks'
freedom is [INAUDIBLE]..
And she was really trying
to challenge the idea
that if we are going to fight
on behalf of black people,
we have to fight on behalf of
black girls and women, as well.
And that there is a very
specific type of experience
that black women have
in relationship to race.
And that patriarchy
is a part of racism
when it comes to black women.
And that if we don't have
those conversations--
but more importantly, if we
don't practice differently,
we're going to just end
up in the very same cycle
that we've been in and
not gaining the things
that we really want to gain.
So it's important, I think, if
you value the lives of people--
this is a conversation
about what we value.
If we value that certain
people's lives need to be
prioritized, because we've
seen them be deprioritized--
if we value that all human
beings deserve to be treated
well--
with dignity and
with care, then we're
going to be able to have more
nuanced conversations about not
just Black Lives Matter, but Me
Too, Women's March, Time's Up--
I mean, the Immigrant
Rights movement--
all these movements are in
relationship to one another.
And I think it's important--
sometimes we get caught up
in the rhetoric of politics,
and I like to reel it back a
bit and remind people of values.
What are our values?
And that is often the place
where it opens up something new
for people to have a different
type of conversation--
about these things
that often can feel
very challenging to talk about.
SPEAKER: On the issue of
black women, in particular--
with the election of Trump--
and it's one of the things
you mentioned in your book
is that you felt particularly
powerless because 96% of black
women didn't vote for Trump.
And with the Jones election--
this idea that black women
essentially, like, saved
the state of Alabama--
(WHISPERING)
whatever that means.
Like, do you think that
this is a pivotal moment
of looking at black women as
a part of electoral power?
Or, do you think that there's
sort of just as a passing
concern now, since we had these
consecutive elections where
the numbers were so stark?
PATRISSE CULLORS: I
think, in a lot of ways,
black women
historically have always
been at the helm of movements.
We've always been at
the sort of intersection
of both trying to save our
families and save the world.
And what we're seeing--
and what we saw with the
election of '45 and with
the election of getting
Roy Moore not into office--
is black women
galvanizing our power
and being strategic about it.
You know, I think there was
a big fight because people
were like, well, why
did you go for Jones?
And folks had to counter
that and say, actually,
this was strategic.
You know, this is the other
person that was running,
and we needed to make
sure we didn't have
this other person in charge.
So this idea I think,
often, that happens
is that black people
just sort of, like,
naturally do these things,
or we don't have a plan.
Or there's no strategy,
or it's all organic.
Sometimes those things are true.
But oftentimes, people
have a strategy--
like Rosa Parks.
It's very upsetting that people
think that Rosa Parks just
sat down on a chair.
And then some white guy
came over, and she was like,
I'm not going to get up today--
it's not how it happened, y'all.
There was a strategy behind
it, and she was a strategist.
I mean, she was one of our
most brilliant strategists.
And we don't hear
that very often.
We don't get that story.
We get this very ageist,
weird, like, feminizing story
of how she just happened to be
too old and tired to get up.
Rather then they sat in rooms,
trying to figure out how
were they going to
boycott this system--
that literally got almost
all the black population
to work and to school.
How do you convince
black people to not
get on a bus that can jeopardize
their jobs and their schooling?
And that moment with
Rosa Parks not getting up
is just the moment.
But there was all
these other moments
before that got us there.
And so I think that's important.
Because part of what the book
is trying to do is also really
let people know that
there is a strategy.
And so much of the time
that Black Lives Matter
has been developing, there
has been all this criticism--
what do you all really
want, what are your goals?
And this book is trying to
lay the record straight.
SPEAKER: So I want to make
sure that we have a lot of time
for questions from the floor.
So I have one last question I
want to make sure to ask you,
and then we'll open up.
So if you want to start
lining at the microphone,
we'll do that.
A question-- one
of the things that
is a theme that you draw
for the entirety of the book
is this idea of your
community, and you're always
pulling people.
And I think one of the things
that you said that I thought
was very powerful is that "they
wouldn't let me be erased,
I will never let
them be erased."
Can you speak a
little bit as to why
black community, in particular,
is so important to you?
Like, what is it
about your community
that you feel is
necessary in, sort of,
the world we're living in today?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Yeah.
I mean, I think this
is a simple answer.
Which is, I grew up around
some of the most brilliant
and talented and
powerful people--
my siblings, my parents.
And yet, they received
very, very little support
for their gifts, their talents.
And that is solely based off of
race and racism and classism.
And so to witness
that, I also ended up--
and I talk about
this in the book--
I end up being sort of plucked
from my elementary school
and labeled as gifted.
And so I go to a
totally separate system
than my siblings do,
which happens to make
me see how other people live.
Because you don't know how
other people live unless you go
see it.
And in that
experience, you know,
going from my own neighborhood--
which was a small suburb,
outside of the inner city of
Los Angeles that was mostly poor
working class, surrounded
by white suburb--
and that's where I ended
up going to school.
I got to see, firsthand,
just how classism plays out,
just how racism plays out.
And that just based off of your
socio and economic background,
or your race-- that
your entire life changes
and what's predicted for you.
And so, you know, I always
say my mother would be, like,
the most amazing therapist.
She's, like, the
person who I learned
how to have important and
courageous conversations from.
And yet, she was
relegated to menial jobs
because she never got a middle
school diploma, high school
diploma.
And so there's these things--
these barriers-- that exist
for poor folks that are solely
because people don't have money.
And I think for the community I
grew up in-- black communities
in particular--
there's this longing
that I have to be
fully seen and fully
realized, because I
know what gifts we have.
AUDIENCE: So how do
you deal with trying
to put forward the ideas
of Black Lives Matter
and deal with the fact that
people-- rightly or wrongly--
get very antagonized
and go-- well, all lives
matter, or blue lives matter?
Like, as the opposite
of Black Lives Matter.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Right.
In a lot of different ways--
depends on the audience,
depends on the person.
You know, some days I choose not
to even answer those questions,
just for my own sanity.
Because the reality is-- and for
folks who are in the room who
are sort of on the fence around
all lives matter versus Black
Lives Matter--
all lives do matter.
That's actually not
the argument right now.
And Black Lives Matter is really
just Black Lives Matter, too.
And so Black Lives Matter
is not about exclusion,
it's about focusing.
And doesn't a community,
who has spent 500 years
in this country, get to decide
how we focus our energy?
And aren't we allowed
to ask people-- allies--
to join us in this fight?
And I think what I try to do in
those conversations is really
challenge people--
sometimes gently,
sometimes not so gently--
about what kind of world
do you want to live in?
Do you want to live
in a world where
the state is allowed to execute
people and get away with it?
Do you want to live in
a world where someone
can get stopped for a broken
taillight, end up in jail,
and then not survive it?
Do you want to live in a world
where people, only because they
don't have physical
papers, are allowed
to be ripped from their
families and deported back
to their so-called countries?
What kind of world do
we want to live in?
That's what Black Lives
Matter is asking us.
It's asking us to think about
the world we want to live in.
And OK, if you want
to live in a world
where terrible things
happen to human beings, then
maybe I shouldn't be
talking to you about this.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is-- aside from your work--
what's one piece of literature
or art or entertainment
that right now, in this
moment that we're in,
really gives you
hope for the future?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Oh,
that's a good one.
Well, I really love
Octavia Butler--
other people in the audience?
AUDIENCE: Whoop!
PATRISSE CULLORS: OK, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
Appreciate it!
Although it's kind of
sinister-- sometimes morbid--
she opens up a portal
around how to have
really hard conversations
about race and class and gender
in some of the most beautiful
and courageous and innovative
ways.
And more pop culture--
I definitely think the
work that Issa Rae is doing
and Lena Waithe is
doing, in particular,
is very exciting and powerful
and fresh and innovative.
Yeah, that's what I got for you.
AUDIENCE: So thank
you again for coming.
I understand that you were
awarded a Peace Prize.
PATRISSE CULLORS: I was.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
a little bit about that?
PATRISSE CULLORS:
The irony of that!
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So congratulations,
if people here don't know.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: And can
you talk a little bit
about what you've seen in how
the movement has been received
outside the US,
versus inside the US?
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Yeah, you always
like something better
when it's outside.
The Black Lives
Matter Global Network
received the Sydney
Peace Prize last year--
very amazing.
I had no idea what it
was before I received it.
And when we received it, I
looked it up and I was like,
oh, this is a very big deal.
And folks like Naomi
Klein have received it.
Desmond Tutu has received it,
Noam Chomsky has received it.
And I think we were
literally the youngest
people who ever received
the Sydney Peace Prize.
And we were not only welcomed
by the country of Australia,
we were welcomed by black
folks in Australia--
aboriginal population,
first nations people.
And also, really
welcomed by the media.
I mean, it was a very,
very different experience
than that type of
experience we've had here
starting Black Lives Matter.
And I think it also
challenged this idea
of us being a terrorist
group or organization.
Because someone wrote about it.
They're like, Black Lives
Matter just won a Peace Prize,
you could stop calling them
a terrorist organization.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's been very powerful to--
the folks of Australia
were looking to us
around how they deal with race
and racism in their country.
And how to really have
a new type of movement
that's hopefully going
to bubble up there.
And it was more than inspiring,
more than I could ever
have imagined.
And I'm very grateful
that our network was
honored with the Peace Prize.
SPEAKER: But I actually
want to follow up
on the term terrorist,
because it's a term that
is very important in your book.
PATRISSE CULLORS:
It's the title.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Exactly-- that's
how you know it's important.
Can you speak a
little bit as to why
that word has so much power?
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Well, raise your hand
if you or people
in your community
have ever been
called a terrorist?
Raise your hand high.
Now, look around-- right.
So the first time
Black Lives Matter
is called a terrorist
organization,
there's two things
that come up for me.
The first one is devastation.
Because, simply, I'm with
these folks every single day.
I know exactly what we're doing.
I know what type of
sacrifice we're giving.
The other is a sense
of serious fear.
Because the moment
the government
starts calling
people terrorists,
that means there's going
to be a war on the people.
And so I think what's
important in this book,
and the conversation
I'm trying to have,
is what do we mean
when we mean terrorist,
and who ends up being
labeled as such?
And what we've seen, especially
for black people in this
country, is whenever we decide
that we're going to fight
for our freedom-- that we're
going to fight for our dignity,
we're going to fight
for our humanity--
that there's a label
that is slapped on us,
or our community, to
undermine our efforts,
but also to criminalize
our efforts.
And so what we've
seen-- and I'll just
ask another question of the
audience-- how many of you
have heard of the Black
Identity Extremists label?
Yeah.
Who made that up?
AUDIENCE: Jeff Sessions.
PATRISSE CULLORS: What?
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was Jeff Sessions?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Yeah, FBI.
It was probably Jeff Sessions--
[LAUGHTER]
--with the FBI.
He's definitely
defending that identity.
An identity that was literally
crafted and created by the FBI.
And many of us saw
it in a leaked report
that came out in August 2017.
And the report, literally, is
claiming that black activists
have a new identity, in which
we are more violent towards law
enforcement.
And for many of us that
have studied movements,
or have elders in the movement--
like Angela Davis, Ericka
Huggins.
In our conversations with
them, they are like, yeah,
this is the beginning of what
it looks like to be criminalized
by the state for your activism.
Similar to what COINTELPRO did.
And so the terrorist
conversation
is interrogating this idea that
black activists-- people who
are literally trying to fight
for American democracy--
are terrorists.
And yet, the people who are
trying to change and reform
are terrorizing our communities.
And how much we have to be
challenging those terms,
challenging that language,
and showing up differently,
I think, in this moment.
What is different
from 30, 40 years ago
is there were no
elected officials trying
to fight for the Panther Party.
Now, given what we
know about COINTELPRO--
given that we know that they
assassinated people, ripped
families apart, and ripped
a really powerful movement
apart--
there are elected
officials, specifically
the Congressional Black Caucus,
that is standing up to the FBI
around this term.
And Congresswoman Karen Bass
has been leading the crusade
around that.
SPEAKER: There are a
couple of questions.
AUDIENCE: You
talked a little bit
about the virality of the
Black Lives Matter hashtag.
And so, I guess,
I'm interested in--
so, like, in recent times Trump
has kind of taken over news.
And, like, you hear a
lot about white supremacy
and you hear a lot about these
other things that kind of suck
up all of the media attention.
And I'm wondering,
like, to what extent
do you think it's important
for Black Lives Matter
to have that viral aspect?
And, like, what's the future
of the Black Lives Matter
movement in an environment
where it becomes
more difficult to have a voice?
PATRISSE CULLORS: That's
great, it's a great question.
Well, what I will say is
sometimes in movements,
you need to be a
little bit more quiet.
Being out there all the
time makes you vulnerable,
and it's made us vulnerable.
And sometimes, that's
not always for the best.
So going viral is not
the goal, necessarily--
it has a great outcome.
I think the better question is
how do we sustain ourselves?
And especially as we are
building out a global network,
how do we create an
infrastructure, an institution
power, that can challenge
the current power structure?
That's what we're most
interested in this moment--
we're interested
in the long haul.
And I think we're
on to something,
and I think we are developing
a new type of experiment that
is centering black
folks, in particular.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you for speaking to
us, today, you are amazing.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask you
a question about how you think
capitalism and large capitalist
entities, such as Google,
may affect Black Lives Matter--
either positively or negatively?
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Such a good question.
Hmm.
Well, what I will say is living
in this current infrastructure
that we live in-- that is, a
capitalist infrastructure--
is not sustainable for anybody.
And as the rich literally get
richer and the poor literally
get poorer, we have to
have a long term solution.
Not only how we're going
to save human beings,
but how we're going
to save the planet.
And we, unfortunately,
have an administration
that doesn't believe
in climate change.
It, like, drives me nuts, y'all.
Like, we're literally
burning up in some places.
And other places are drowning,
because the Earth's equilibrium
is so off.
And so I think the long
term conversation is,
is capitalism a
sustainable model?
And many of us know it's not.
So what does that mean?
And that I don't
have an answer to,
but I have a lot
of questions about.
And I think our movement,
often, is trying to figure that
out and have questions about.
I think, you know, Google is
such an interesting place,
right?
It's worldwide.
It's a huge corporation.
It also will bring one of the
co-founders of Black Lives
Matter to talk to its employees.
It's, like, such an
interesting contradiction.
And my hope is that--
I'm not going to be able to
change Google, necessarily.
But I think the hope,
in this certain moment,
is to change the hearts and
minds of people who work here.
And how we make
decisions about how
we relate to the planet
and other human beings.
AUDIENCE: That was beautiful.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Let me-- oh,
there's a question.
No?
Please, go ahead.
I have already spoken way
more than anyone wants.
AUDIENCE: So I had
a different take
on-- so you mentioned about
the strategic goals of making
a sustainable movement
for long term.
Specifically around
some of the things that
sparked the movement, right--
police brutalities,
unjust violence--
do you or does the movement
have charterdom goals--
either through activism or
legislative changes through
time--
planned on some of
the more egregious
policing tactics, the ridiculous
use of force type of mandates?
Are there specific
codes around that?
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Yeah, actually.
I was just on a
phone call about it,
before I got here,
talking to our lawyers.
It's a great question because
someone asked me-- well,
"Time Magazine" asked me
the other day and said,
will there ever be
a Me Too of racism?
And I was like, well--
it's called Black Lives Matter.
[LAUGHTER]
But what I think
is interesting--
I think what he was trying
to ask, actually, was--
Me Too has been successful
at literally knocking down
some of the biggest power
players in Hollywood.
I mean, people that
we never thought
would be sort of taken out, you
know, taken out of Hollywood--
have been.
Whether or not they
have huge pensions,
if they could still
live their lives--
it's a whole other question.
But symbolically,
what that has shown
us is that sexual assault
and violence is not going
to be taken lightly anymore.
And he was trying
to ask-- well, how
come we haven't had the same
impact on law enforcement?
And what I did is I
said, well, that's
not Black Lives
Matter fault. We've
done everything we can to hold
law enforcement accountable.
But rather, we have
to have a larger
conversation about
the people who
keep law enforcement in power--
elected officials, county
board of supervisors,
state governors, the laws.
I mean, in the US, I think
there's over 22 Peace Officer
Bill of Rights, right?
Which literally are a
document that gives rights
to peace officers that
pretty much excludes them
from being held
accountable for their acts.
California and Seattle
have some of the worst
Police Officer Bill of Rights.
And so much of what
we're trying to do
is go state by state,
city by city, county
by county changing those laws.
The first experiment is
going to be California.
Because we have some of
the most egregious laws,
but also because we
have some of the most
progressive legislators.
So can we get enough
legislators to say we
can't allow this
to happen anymore.
Can we get enough district
attorneys to say--
because it's in a
district attorney's
right to prosecute an officer.
But they, more
often, err on not.
So the work, I think,
is in the next phase--
specifically around law
enforcement violence
is trying to change laws.
I think that we've hit a road.
We have to take things
to the ballot box
and galvanize our movement
to push new laws forward.
AUDIENCE: And just
a quick follow up.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have a specific view
on the use of body cameras?
PATRISSE CULLORS: I do, I do.
We have cell phones--
so that's one.
Body cameras are millions
and millions of dollars.
And oftentimes, that
accountability--
I'm going to flip it--
the responsibility
is on the officer to
turn on the body camera.
So how many times have we
seen law enforcement not
turn on their body camera?
AUDIENCE: But, seriously.
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Almost all the time.
And so I think it's
an interesting demand.
But if we make body
cameras as the solution
to ending law
enforcement violence,
then we've lost a long time ago.
AUDIENCE: The term
terrorism has erupted,
because there has been
some incidents in time
that some protests--
where there, you know,
there may be violence
that has occurred, right?
Do you ever come to a point
where your organization just
comes out and flat out, you
know, denounce something?
And say, you know, this is not
something that we condoned--
sometimes you
cannot be, you know,
responsible for everybody
who is at the protest.
But is there, in the same way,
where you ally with some people
for the same cause,
and you know,
under the name of [INAUDIBLE]----
yo, do I hate that word--
but do you do both?
Is there a time where
you throw the power
of the network behind
a cause and you
follow through with it--
that may not be necessarily
under the broad umbrella
of Black Lives Matter?
And is there a
time where you see
some things, either a protest or
even inside your own movement,
where you go out there and
you just denounce it, gladly?
PATRISSE CULLORS: I mean, yes.
I think the Dallas shooting
we denounced immediately.
Michael Johnson and I talked
about that in the book.
But you know, there's never
been a shooting from someone
who's said that they did it on
behalf of Black Lives Matter--
it's always been attributed
to Black Lives Matter.
And our movement from
jump has been nonviolent.
I mean, that's just been clear.
In fact, we've been
calling for law enforcement
to stop killing us, right?
And I think the
conversation about violence
versus nonviolence
is a really important
political conversation.
And frankly, we're in a
different time period.
You know, the Panthers went on
Sacramento steps and had guns.
And we would never do that
because we see the result--
a black person doesn't
need a gun to get killed.
So I think for us, the most
effective and safe strategy
is a nonviolent strategy,
in this particular moment.
AUDIENCE: Can I just ask
a quick follow up to this?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: So in social media,
usually whatever the hashtag
is, and the virality
of things, you know,
over the power of
the narrative--
so if tomorrow something was
going on with the movement
and I wanted to check--
OK, what's the official
word from your network?
Where would I go?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Oh,
that's a good question.
You mean, like on what
social media pages?
AUDIENCE: Right-- pages, or
just online, or websites.
PATRISSE CULLORS: So
BlackLivesMatter.com
is our website.
On Facebook, we're verified.
Do not use any other Facebook
profile, because there's tons--
and they're not verified,
and some of them
will steal your money.
And on Twitter, we are
Black Lives Matter,
but we're @Blklivesmatter.
And same on Instagram.
And the most
updated, like, stand
that we have on something
is usually going
to be on our Twitter account.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for speaking.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I had a question about
intersectionality and the labor
movement-- like--
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Where do they lie?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
I mean, I don't think
police unions should
be able to bargain
whether or not they
respect people's human rights.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Yes.
[CHUCKLE]
AUDIENCE: Can the
labor movement still
be an ally to
Black Lives Matter?
PATRISSE CULLORS: This
is such a good question.
And these are, you know--
I've sat with a lot of
Labor folks around this.
So much so that we've
really challenged
Labor to have law enforcement
as part of their union.
I think, honestly,
in a lot of places,
law enforcement is
the strongest union--
they have the most lawyers,
they have the most money,
and they have a lot of power.
So when we talk to
presidents and we've
talked to union
organizers, they're
a pain in the butt in unions.
They are, because
they're the first ones
to stop any sort of
democratic process,
or challenge any sort
of progressive statement
the union wants to put out.
But until union
leadership stands up
to law enforcement
unions, we're going
to continue in the same cycle.
And I think, you know,
I spoke to one of--
I don't remember which Black
Panther member said this
to us-- but they
said that we are
the first effective movement
to actually challenge
law enforcement,
to actually curb
the community and
the culture that
believes law enforcement first.
And that to me is just the
beginning of really trying
to change the seats of power.
But right now, law
enforcement still
has all the bargaining chips.
AUDIENCE: An earlier
question asked you
what in art gives you hope.
What in politics-- and I
think we all hope for 2020--
but what else could
you hope in politics?
And I'm an engineer, I'm not
going to be a global activist.
What can I do?
PATRISSE CULLORS: Great,
that's a great question.
OK, two things.
One, I'm going to start with
your last question-- what can
you do.
Everybody has their lane.
I think that you don't have
to go out into the streets
to be active, to be aware, to
challenge awful things that
happen to people.
You can have conversations, you
can be a part of book clubs,
you could be a
part of dialogues.
I think even coming into this
room is an act of solidarity,
and a show of good faith.
We also come from families--
how we're raising our children,
how we're talking to our wives,
our husbands, ours sisters,
our brothers.
You know, when I usually
get the question around how
can white people help--
the first thing I say is go
talk to your family members.
Have those hard and
challenging conversations
that we often say--
oh, I'm just going to
ignore that-- right?
I think how we're living our
lives is just as important as
if you're out in the streets
being politically active.
What was your first question?
AUDIENCE: What, in
politics, gives you hope?
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Political hope-- right.
I'm excited about
how many people that
are running for
office-- that are
folks of color, women of color.
I'm excited about
the conversations
that are happening
around political power.
I'm excited about how engaged--
I mean, I've been in this
work for a long time.
And my mother never
talks about politics.
And she'll, like, call
me and curse out Trump.
And I'm like, oh, you're
feeling engaged in this moment.
Even if it's against
a person, there's
something about
this moment that's
making people want to do more
than they've ever done before.
And on the one hand, it's
devastating to witness
so many executive
orders totally just
rip through our constitution.
And on the other hand, it's
brilliant to see so many people
saying no, I'm not
going to stand for this.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: I want to make sure--
wait, no microphone.
There you go.
I want to make sure we leave
some time for signing--
and not just because
people are like, no--
I have more questions.
I want to make sure we
leave some time for signing.
And for people to
actually get the book.
So again, thank you.
PATRISSE CULLORS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: We really appreciate
you taking the time.
PATRISSE CULLORS:
Thank you all so much.
SPEAKER: Thank you
all for everything.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRISSE CULLORS: Thank
you, I really appreciate it.